[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday
it was a year ago this month we checked
the calendar that a university chicago
economics professor
called harold eulig questioned in public
the wisdom of defunding the police
now euleg is german by birth he's a
macro economist by trade so he's a
fairly
rational person it's his job and it
struck harold yuling that maybe a
functional society
might want to have police around so that
say old ladies don't get beaten up on
the way to the grocery store and fewer
people get shot to death
less rapes you know the basics that
seemed reasonable to him
unfortunately for harold eulek in the
weeks right after george floyd's death
extending to the present day
rational thinking of any kind has been
prohibited by law
nothing that is true can be said out
loud the truer it is the more forbidden
it is
so in eulog's case the federal reserve
of chicago promptly fired him from his
job as an advisor
then they went online to attack him and
his support for the police as
quote not compatible with our commitment
to diversity equity and inclusion
all of which require no police
apparently then the university
of chicago his employer began an
investigation into harold eulig's racial
views which went on for some time
then janet yellen then the chairman of
the fed now the secretary of the
treasury
denounced euleg effectively as a racist
everybody did defund the police we'll be
safer
if we do that's what they were saying a
year ago everyone in charge
it was lunacy and precisely because
it was lunacy no one was allowed to
disagree with it here's the formula
the more self-evidently absurd a
statement is
the more clearly untrue the more
viciously they have to attack
anyone who points out that it's untrue
who descends
trans women are women january 6 was an
insurrection to fund the police
it's childish it's all so ridiculous and
no sane
person believes a word of it but until
the fever of the moment passes
most people who have no power feel
obligated to play along with whatever
orthodoxy it is until reality re-emerges
as
inevitably it does because you can't
beat nature
in the case of crime that may be
happening now the white house announced
today that on wednesday of this week joe
biden will outline a new plan to fight
rising crime rates which are
skyrocketing and the body counts that
accompany them
now we haven't seen the plan we can't
know what's in it the white house won't
tell us
but we do have two fairly informed
guesses for what we're going to discover
on wednesday
first there will be no apologies you
will not hear
joe biden beg forgiveness from the
thousands of families whose
loved ones have been killed by the
democratic party's nihilistic embrace of
crime and disorder looting his
reparations you go looters
they should apologize for that they
never will the left's ideology destroyed
america's cities but they will never
under any circumstances admit that
ever instead they will blame you that's
guaranteed
our second guess is this whatever
democrats propose to fix the problems
that they created will in the end make
them
more powerful see how that works they
create a problem
and the solution empowers them that's
always
the way it goes so with that in mind we
expect joe biden to remind us on
wednesday who the real criminals are who
the threat
is people who didn't vote for joe biden
or as joe biden himself puts it white
supremacists we've taken steps to
acknowledge and address
systemic racism and the scourge of white
supremacy in our own country yes
forced us to confront systemic racism
and white supremacy it's just been weeks
since
all america witnessed a group of thugs
insurrectionists
a political extremist and white
supremacist violently attacked
the capital of our democracy i believe
we're in a battle for the soul of this
nation
and the simple truth is our soul will be
troubled as long as systemic racism is
allowed to persist
yes white supremacy is america's biggest
problem as we've noted many times before
we still don't know
despite fervent and sincere efforts to
find out
what a white supremacist is the white
house has not told us they have refused
so as of tonight that remains a term
without definition by the way if you've
got a definition send it to us we'll
read it on the air
but they don't need a definition they
keep screaming it's the greatest threat
we face
so because we're highly literal on the
show we believe in language we went
searching for the numbers are there
numbers to prove that because there are
numbers on everything
well they're busy trying to create those
numbers now but for the moment here's
we've got
researchers at the university of
maryland run something called the global
terrorism database some of the data they
produce are clearly highly political for
example
they count the parkland school shooting
as an act of white supremacist violence
it wasn't
there's no evidence that it was how
could you say that but they say it
anyway
so the numbers they have are inflated
and yet
the researchers at the university of
maryland could find fewer than
70 people in the entire country who died
from white supremacist violence
over the entire period between 2015 and
2019.
how many people is that well of course
it's too many any death is too many
but for some perspective more people die
in this country
every year from lightning strikes
literally
look it up so no white supremacist
violence
bad as it may be is not a major threat
it's not even on the list
actually what's at the top of the list
well let's see
crime crime tops the list there's no
second place on that list in the year
2019 alone there were more than 10
000 arrests for murder in this country
by the way more murders than that but
ten thousand were arrested
just in 2020 last year more than 750
people were murdered
just in the city of chicago 750
and we can say not that anyone's asking
but in case you're wondering with some
confidence
that the overwhelming majority of those
suspects in the city of chicago were not
practicing white supremacists or members
of q anon
how do we know this well an informed
guest but in some cases there's video
for example this show has obtained
exclusive surveillance footage of a
shooting that took place this weekend a
horrifying shooting
on the northwest side of chicago this
one took place right after puerto rican
day parade
there you may may have seen abbreviated
version of this clip on social media
today we have the full version it's on
your screen as we speak
it's taken directly from a closed
circuit television camera in the city of
chicago
now as you watch this ask yourself
what country is that it's america
it's not some third world hellhole it's
not haiti it's a major street
in your third largest city
so a couple with the puerto rican flag
waving from their car apparently minding
their own business
ambushed by a mob dragged from the car
and shot execution style
right in the middle of the road the men
who shoot them
take off and then maybe the worst part
the victims just lie they're bleeding
because nobody comes to help
again what country is this who's running
it
and why haven't we brought those people
up on felony neglect charges
they deserve it if we accept a country
where things like this happen then we
are the savages we should not accept it
joe biden does though
he hasn't said a word about that
shooting and he won't because there are
no white supremacists to blame
it's one crime he'll never mention
here's podcam video of the horrific
altercation
the brother who didn't want to be
identified says his brother had
rear-ended a parked car
after that a group of up to six men
inside of that car
jumped out started attacking them and
also
throwing up gang signs 24-year-old
giovanni arzugo was shot in the head
hip and thigh he died at st mary's
hospital
his wife 23 year old yasmin perez was
shot in the neck
and remains in critical condition
shot in the neck and just laid there
with no one helping
but that wasn't the only shooting this
weekend in chicago far
from it in chicago a city by the way
that just
banned its own police from chasing
suspects on foot
in all 54 people were shot in chicago
this weekend and it wasn't just
happening there chicago gets a lot of
attention but it's not
constrained to chicago in new york where
the geniuses also defunded the police
surveillance footage shows two children
were nearly shot to death on thursday in
the middle of an attempted murder
in the middle of the day watch this
this disturbing surveillance video shows
a gunman firing his weapon
at a 24 year old man inches away from
two young children
brother and sister ages 10 and 5. it
happened in broad daylight thursday
the kids were walking to this bodega
before they were caught in the middle of
this
at one point you can see the sister
trying to shield her younger brother
with her own body
so normal people watching that would say
to themselves whatever we're doing we
have to change
you can't have things like this innocent
people are getting killed even guilty
people are getting killed people are
getting killed flat out
and we can't have that because we're a
civilized society this is a decent
nation
and you the one thing you can't allow is
that
and yet that's not the conclusion
they're reaching by the way new polling
there's a
mayor's race going on the city of new
york right now the primary's tomorrow
which in effect
is the election because it's a
democratically controlled city
fewer than 20 of new yorkers would like
to see fewer cops on the street so most
people aren't with
for this at all because it's insane but
the people in charge
apparently haven't noticed so now
new york may change its approach even
further
in the wrong direction just days ago
officials in the city announced they
were dropping charges
against hundreds of rioters and looters
who were arrested last year
so you wreck the city and you're not
punished
it's scary but it's not as scary as the
attitudes on display
in this clip this really gets you asking
deep questions about the future of the
country this is from oakland california
now several people were shot one died
during juneteenth celebrations this
weekend
that's bad but the worst part is how
people
in the neighborhood reacted they didn't
seem bothered at all
here's how they responded to the
ambulance when it arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
last week we showed you footage of
people in chicago dancing on a police
cruiser and now we have this
sociopaths and that is the word for them
celebrating a
shooting by twerking what kind of
society
produces people like that who would
behave like that do you know anyone
who'd behave like that
when you see people behave like that you
have to ask yourself
what are we as a society doing wrong is
it no fathers is it the schools who
knows what the
answer is but if we're not trying to
find the answer
they're going to be guaranteed more of
it anyone who'd celebrate a
shooting is not someone you want to
share a country with so we should fix
that
is there a more important task probably
not
but it's completely ignored instead our
irresponsible
low iq political leaders patronize us
with the same
mindless talking points the same talk
about gun control
and assault weapons like ar-15s are the
problem
and not our political class which is
clearly the problem
here for example we can show you many
examples but here's just one this is
the mayor of chicago lori lightfoot
featured in a local news report
tuesday little cayden swann was shot on
lake shore drive
18 others were shot five of them died
wednesday mayor lori lightfoot said part
of the crime issue
is gun control if you can go over the
border in indiana
and literally buy military grade weapons
with any
at any quantity cpd numbers show that
crime is up
around this time last year there were
521 people
shot now that number is 743.
it's tiresome even to repeatedly but
again because we
are literal and connected to physical
reality we feel honor bound to tell you
once more something that laurie
lightfoot of course knows herself
virtually every gun crime in the city of
chicago
is committed with a handgun not with an
ar-15 virtually no crimes nationwide are
committed with
assault weapons so why is she focused on
assault weapons well because the people
who own assault weapons
don't live in chicago and didn't vote
for her
so she'd be happy to disarm them and the
bite administration of course feels the
same way
that's why in march the white house's
lawyers argued before the supreme court
of the united states in a development
that did not get the attention
it deserved that police should be able
to enter the homes of law-abiding
american citizens and
seize their firearms without a warrant
no judge involved
neither any finding of mental impairment
or threat of violence or any of that
in other words your means of
self-defense
belong to the biden administration right
this will not solve crime it will only
disarm you
the real problems here have nothing to
do with the weapons used and nothing to
do with the race of the people
committing the crimes
it's not a black person problem it's not
a white person problem it's not white
supremacy it's not black supremacy
it's bad leadership by the people in
charge
and it's on display all around us
prosecutors many of them funded by
one man george soros refusing to enforce
the law and the results are immediate in
the city of philadelphia for example
where george soros helped elect larry
krasner as the d.a
arrests are hitting record levels but
convictions are dropping in other words
the cops are doing their part
and the prosecutors are refusing to do
theirs result
the city is now on pace to far exceed
its murder rate
from 30 years ago 1990 was the previous
high they're about to beat it
so what happens when prosecutors do
enforce the law and use it to target the
people committing crimes
well that's the way the country used to
work and by the way it works and we have
new academic research tonight to show
that researchers at the university of
pennsylvania and princeton
found that gang takedowns by cops
explained nearly a quarter of all
reduction in so-called
gun violence in housing projects in new
york city after 2011. in other words you
go after the people you know are
committing the crimes
and then you've got a lot less crime the
gangs are committing the crimes in these
cities particularly in chicago
so if joe biden was serious about
protecting children from being murdered
on the street or people at the puerto
rican day parade
from getting killed next to their car he
would go after the gangs
oh but he's probably not going to do
that on wednesday he's also not going to
say a
word about prosecutors like larry
krasner
funded by his friend george soros
calling them to enforce the law
no we also don't think he's going to
call on criminals to stop
twerking on ambulances in oakland or
police cars in chicago
those are biden voters the people joe
biden is going to target
on wednesday are the ones who don't
support him and live far from the
collapsing cities in other words
it's your fault he'll tell you that you
watch hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else